Uh, we have this guy who calls into the show
every once in a while.
We haven't heard from him for months.
His name is Troy York.
He calls in with different characters.
One of them is I believe Jamal Jenkins who
is a black character.
He has another one named Ramon Ramos who is
his Hispanic character.
You can tell that he doesn't know what's going
on because he pronounces the name remotes,
which is of course not the way that that last
name is pronounced in Spanish, which is Ramos.
The emphasis on the a here is Troy York as
Ramon remos as he says, asking if I think
Baltimore is so great in relation to Donald
Trump's recent comments.
Why didn't my family moved to Baltimore when
we came to the United States from Argentina?
Take a listen to Troy.
Slash Ramon.
All right, David Pacman.
This is Ramon.
Well, both.
Um, I still have a question for you.
Um, okay.
I know you came like as immigrant like me,
um, for Latin America and you, you came from
Israel in Argentina.
Most of those countries, I think we'll leave
you say Argentina, but, uh, I believe you
could be trying national.
Okay.
I noticed that you did not, uh, what you immigrated
your, you did not consider the city of Baltimore
for residency in, uh, I was wondering why.
Okay.
This probably is because Trump, what Trump
said was the truth.
Yeah.
No, in fact, we didn't consider any place
other than the one town which had a hospital
at which my dad got a job.
So it's actually far less exciting and interesting
than that.
Um, and, uh, I, I hate to break it to you.
It was not there.
We didn't consider Santa Barbara, California,
which is just a beautiful place.
We didn't consider Miami Beach, which I love.
We didn't consider, you know, Montreal, which
is not the United States, but it's just such
a lovely city, uh, that I love.
Uh, we were in western Massachusetts because
that's where my dad got a job, and that's
basically the full story.
Uh, okay.
We have a tremendous bonus show.
This is actually funny.
The stories on today's bonus show are the
same ones that I promoted yesterday.
Uh, because yesterday we had our, um, biannual
tech fiasco wherein the bonus show imploded.
If you've never seen video recordings implode,
it's a sight to behold.
Yesterday's bonus show imploded and we lost
it.
We lost the bonus show.
I explained it in full on yesterday's bonus
show.
So today we really are going to talk about
the Magda hat wearing kids.
$250 million lawsuit has been dismissed obviously
because it was bogus from day one.
Fitness trackers like the one I wear turns
out that the 10,000 step goal may be overblown
if one is trying to achieve maximum health
benefit.
And we will also talk about, economists are
now saying that Donald Trump's administration
is overpaying farmers for trade losses.
We already talked about how farmers are being
destroyed by Donald, uh, tariffs on China
and other places.
And we also talk about how it is almost like
a form of socialism, which Donald Trump claims
to oppose to pay the farmers for their trade
losses.
And now we're learning that it appears as
though the administration is actually overpaying
farmers for those trade losses.
So we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Leave me a voicemail if you like it.
Two one nine two.
David P, uh, send an email if you want using
the contact form on our website, but most
importantly, get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at www dot join [inaudible]
dot com or by becoming a patron at patrion.com/david
Pacman.
Yeah, I'll speak to you though, the David
Pakman show@davidpacman.com [inaudible].